مراسم التتويج المنتظره للملك تشارلز
الثالث فخامه وبهرجه ليست بزائفه بل احياء
تقاليد تعود الى الفعل قصر كشف عن بعض
التفاصيل المتعلقه بمراسم التتويج المقرره
في السادس من شهر مايو المقبل في
كاتدرائيه
في احدث عربه ملكيه وهي عربه اليوبيل
المسي التي صممت للاحتفال بمرور 60 عاما
على اعتلاء الملكه اليزابيث عرش بريطانيا
مده المراسم اقصر من تلك التي استغرقتها
مراسم تنصيب والده تشارلز الراحله قبل 70
عاما الاختلاف بينهما يشمل ايضا حجم الحدث
ليتماشى جزئيا مع العصر الحديث ويعكس ازمه
تكاليف المعيشه الحاليه وبعد الانتهاء من
المراسيم سيعود تشارلز وكاميلا الى قصر
باكينغهام في اقدم عربه ملكيه وهي
العربه الملكيه المذهبه التي تعود الى 260
عاما
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات